protect your bubble calm proud sponsors
of swipe on Sky News
you're watching slide this week we're
going on board that stay with us
luxury travel with a tech twist we look
at innovations on holidays Bionic
barment
how to order a drink from a robot and
Assassin's Creed heads to China north on
vacation in our games review hello and
welcome to swipe the sun is shining and
we're in the holiday mood because this
week we're onboard the world's most
technologically advanced cruise ship
this is the anthem of the Seas it also
happens to be the biggest cruise ship to
ever set sail out of here in Southampton
it doesn't matter how you travel gone
are the days when the journey was the
boring part now with technology there's
so much more to see and to do and have a
go on as kris has been finding out these
are the drink serving droids on a
high-tech cruise ship at the tap of a
button they'll mix up any drink you like
and that's not the only bit of
technology onboard the ship that claims
to be the world's most futuristic
there's an entertainment area with
moving screens controlled by robotic
arms these panels can either join
together or split to give variety to the
way travelers watch TV the reason we
invest in technology for our guest
experience is so that we can create
multiple layers so you can go to a
traditional pub get a pint or you can go
to the Bionic bar and have one of the
robots create a special cocktail you can
go and see a West End show you can see a
traditional comedian or you can go and
be wowed by the show in 270 with all the
technology and Robo screens and Vista
rama's so it's really something for
everybody it's not just cruise ships
that are finding innovative ways to try
and make your holiday better this
connected suitcase called blue smart
claims it will make traveling less
stressful it links up to your smartphone
and can be tracked so you always know
where it is
it also has a digital lock a built in
battery charger and its own scale so you
can tell if you've packed too much and
if that's not enough how about virtual
reality when you're in the air
Qantas and Samsung want to put VR
headsets onto passengers so watching
movies on the back of someone else's
chair could be a thing of the past so
the passengers will get the option of
being able to either see what the
onboard experience is going to be like
so how the plane is traveling going
through the air or even look at the
destination that are going to or perhaps
even look at some movie content in a
completely 3d environment but some say
that this sort of tech is just a gimmick
well frankly I don't need a bionic
barmen thanks very much I'm perfectly
happy with a friendly pleasant human
being preparing a jolly good cocktail
and serving it with a smile the more I
see of 21st century travel the more it
seems completely
unjoined up sure I can buy a train
ticket online but most of the time it's
gonna be a little bit of cardboard with
some writing on it which is a bit of a
19th century idea machine-made mijitos
may not be for everyone but as the
market for travel tech grows it's likely
we'll see more innovations like these
Chris Craig and Sky News it's time we
got a closer look at these robots a
drink can they really make it yes they
can they're very professional bartenders
I'll show you how it's done
basically use your RFID card or your
royal wristbands and you press it onto
the screen here then you can either
choose a drink or you can create a drink
from scratch
so you create the drink there you go in
gin yeah the other few choices mixes
they want tonic water
yeah and ice and I I would like a slice
of lemon
yeah you can choose both can the robot
handle that they can do that of course
and then when you're done you press
order and you'll send it off to the
robots up there and they'll start making
you drink now he's going to go for the
Bombay Sapphire so he's heading up there
it goes I thought I make it a double
been seen any more
are you a slightly threatened that these
guys might do you out of a job at some
point no no I mean bartenders that you
very well at their job they make
fantastic consistent drinks at a very
good rate however I think you'll never
get as good a personality as you will
with someone like me do they have names
yeah the one on the left is called P 100
on the right called
n1c which is short for bio and Nick's a
Bionic which is the same as quantum
we're gonna have some kind of
competition to see
let me get your you're watching swine
coming up Mario's got some fresh
competition I think by oh and Nick might
have had an extra shot edge into that
anyway here's a roundup of some of this
week's other tech news you've seen Robo
barman now check out this robot
receptionist in Japan the lifelike
Android called Aiko Chihiro has been put
to work in a Tokyo shopping center
helping customers with directions at the
moment she can only read out scripts and
can't answer direct questions but an
upgrade has been scheduled students in
Australia are being asked to design a
multi-million dollar national park using
minecraft the competition run by the
country's government will see the
winning submission brought to life using
a six million pound fund entrants have
been asked to incorporate spaces for
outdoor activities like hiking mountain
biking and camping an app for renters
sharing flats or houses could help put
an end to awkward conversations about
money
spit Abel lets you keep track of
household expenses from gas and
electricity to takeaway dinners it adds
up contributions from each user letting
you see who's paid for what and keeps
you updated with regular notifications
finding time to hit the gym can be a
struggle but a new app called Truby
brings a personal trainer to you at a
time and place that suits you most in
just a few taps its initially launching
in London the app plans to extend the
service by offering other activities
like yoga and boxing - now just because
we're having a lot of fun on a cruise
ship this week it doesn't mean we've
forgotten all about our games review
segments have
wait with all this fun going on is Lucy
James Assassin's Creed chronicles China
takes assassin's creed back to its real
roots which was in the Prince of Persia
series and it's 2.5 D so it's on a 2d
plane but you know all the character
models are in 3d it looks absolutely
gorgeous and you play as a new assassin
called Xiao Chun and you can kind of do
these the typical let's have some things
of jumping off high buildings into hay
bales and sneaking up on guards and
killing them but it's it's more in depth
because you do have such a limited
amount of space because all you can see
on the screen you have to really think
about your encounters and try and sneak
past people but it's fun and it's good
for Assassin's Creed fans Maricar 8 came
out last year and it's getting dlc so it
had a first pack of DLC which introduced
new characters and some new tracks and
this is the second one which is all
based around the Nintendo franchise
Animal Crossing so first of all what it
does is you get brand new playable
characters so you have the male and
female villager from Animal Crossing you
get Isabel use the adorable little dog
ping receptionist from Animal Crossing
and dry Bowser and there's also some new
tracks including an animal crossing
themed one which is adorable and it
randomizes whenever you play it so
sometimes when you play it could be
winter and everything snowing it could
be spring and it could be summer it
could be autumn and you have to you know
you can drive into trees and the fruit
will come down and you see different
characters and animal crossing so it's
kind of it's a big thing for fans it's
quite cute
go simulate is kind of cheating because
it came out last year on PC and on
handhelds like mobiles and there isn't
really much you can say about it other
than it is well you do play as a goat so
the gameplay you know you're a goat and
you can jump you can headbutt things you
can even lick things and kind of cling
on to things and it's quite crazy but
the ragdoll physics in it all makes it
hilarious and it's just a lot of fun if
you get some friends to go just to see
how crazy you can make things happen
well I don't call it the high seas for
nothing we're 300 feet up right now and
the cruise ship isn't even moving and
this is pretty scary so I think it's a
good time to say goodbye join us again
next week for more swiping in the
meantime you can stay up to date with
all the latest tech news on Spidey's for
iPad or smartphone apps Guyanese calm
and my youtube playlists see you again
bye bye
protect your bubble comm proud sponsors
of swipe on Sky News